mes chers collègues les prochaines
questions d'actualité au Gouvernement
auront lieu le mercredi 11 octobre mais
je ne vais pas lever la séance sans
rendre hommage à une présidente de
groupe qui a beaucoup apporté au Sénat
je veux rendre hommage à la présidente
Eliane assassin qui préside le groupe
communiste républicain et citoyen
[Applaudissements]
elle a été la sénatrice de l'année 2022
mais avec ses convictions avec son
engagement avec si elle représente son
attachement à la République et cette
forme d'attention aux autres au plus
modestes et au plus pauvre elle incarne
vraiment à la fois de la famille
politique à laquelle elle est tellement
attachée mais aussi une richesse pour
notre Sénat et pour notre République je
voulais la remercier personnellement
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]